we do have a david pakman show subreddit
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t a
few interesting discussions i spotted
this morning including one about alex
jones why alex jones shouldn't be booted
off youtube and social media and this
viewer listener audience member explains
why they don't think despite their
dislike of alex jones that he should be
kicked off all of the platforms off of
which he's been kicked and says that it
is more an issue of speech and
censorship and that the concern is once
which starts with jones who's next and
this is actually a profit of lee
prominent view among many in our
audience another perspective on Alex
Jones from the David Pakman show
subreddit is around Twitter suspending
Alex Jones for seven days over the tweet
over a tweet which we're going to talk
about later in the show I happen to
think that a seven day suspension on
Twitter of Jones is a very carefully
calculated half measure that will
achieve absolutely nothing in terms of
changing Jones's behavior and may in in
some ways actually a grand eyes him even
more but we're gonna talk about that
later and it will upset just about
everyone so it'll solve zero problems
and just make people angrier I tend to
agree but divergent views on the Alex
Jones stuff on the David Pakman show
subreddit also from the David Pakman
show subreddit Michael Moore's
Fahrenheit 11 9 in theaters 921 I had no
idea that Michael Moore was producing
this film and it's been a while since
I've seen a Michael Moore film maybe
because it's been a while since he
produced one I don't know what the last
one was but I'm interested in this and I
don't know if you've seen the preview
pad but it does look interesting it's
sort of a I would call it a look at what
led to Trump in a sense oh you think
it's the lead-up I didn't know if it was
like what's been going on since the
election of trumps or what's going on
yeah it's good what's going on in
connection to how what's going on helps
us understand how we even got here in
the first place I guess a and eleven
nine is reference to the day where Trump
got elected was it well it was November
8th was election day oh okay and it was
after maybe was like
Who I am yeah that's fair okay so at
least accurate when it comes to the
timing of yeah the events that took
place so many of those and other
discussions regularly happening trolling
free on the david pakman show subreddit
at david pakman.com slash our EDD iti'm
on there pat is on there very exciting
stuff this episode is sponsored in part
by better help calm slash Pakman which
gives you access to a fully licensed and
experienced psychologist or therapist
through video phone and text I know from
the emails I get that in our audience
like in the broader world there are
people who are struggling with different
issues in their lives and many of them
choose not to talk to somebody about it
either for financial reasons for reasons
of stigma associated with seeking out a
therapist and I think it's really
important to do everything you can to
get past that because it's really
important to talk to someone when you
feel like that's the right thing to do
and what better help calm provides is
number one the elimination of the stigma
that could be associated with it you
work through video phone whichever
method is best for you
you also will be able to save money
compared to seeing an in-person
therapist and it is so easy to get
started that I encourage you to go to
better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everybody should have
access to go to better help calm slash
Pakman it's easy to sign up it's easy to
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube and once again that website is
better help calm /pa que ma n